So this allows us to now start of course
knowing what H is, and then using that
for being able to now find a warp
between the two different images.
So again let's take these
two different images here.
These two points that I want to actually
be able to model, and of course,
these two points are visible here.
To achieve this first I need
to create a bigger space,
coordinate space like this one.
Then I can put this one here.
Now I know these two points are aligned.
You can put this on top
of each other that way.
And, of course, this means now actually
I'm enable to align these two images.
because I know where
these two points are.
Course, we need to do a little bit more.
We need to also do a little bit of
warping and interpolation, something we
have looked at before, to be able to
align this image with the other one.
Basically, I need to
find the fact that this
is the original image that I actually
have the transformations for.
And, of course, knowing this warp and
interpolation parameters,
I can now generate a much cleaner
image between those two regions.
And that will allow me to kind of
create a much smoother type of an image
between those two.